sie kommen nach einem sehr anstrengenden
arbeitstag nach hause freuen sich auf
einen entspannten feierabend auf der
couch ist schauen sich in ihren vier
wänden um und merken plötzlich ein
fremder ist in ihrer wohnung genau das
ist einem hausbesitzer in bielefeld
jetzt passiert er ertappt den räuber auf
frischer tat und wird lebensgefährlich
verletzt
beamte in schutzanzügen sichern
blutspritzer einbruchs
die nr
was als einfacher einbruch beginnt ist
jetzt ein fall für die mordkommission
rückblick es ist montag später
nachmittag die dunkelheit bricht über
bielefeld herein um 17 uhr 42 beginnt
der albtraum für die besitzer dieses
hauses der 62 jährige kommt heim bemerkt
einbruchsspuren doch er geht ins haus
was er in diesem moment nicht ahnt der
einbrecher ist noch vor ort der zieht
ein messer und sticht auf sein opfer ein
ein einziger stich lebensgefahr
notoperation niemand hat die folge
bluttat beobachtet wir können das hier
einmal sehr schön zeigen denn um das
haus herum steht eine dichte hecke und
die verhindert natürlich die sicht auf
das grundstück das heißt also man wird
überhaupt gar nicht von der straße aus
wasser ein haus hinter der hecke ist und
autofahrer die hier vorbeikommen die
bemerken dann natürlich auch gar nicht
dass hier etwas nicht stimmt fest steht
der täter ist flüchtig im ort bleibt die
angst waren alle gestern geschockt wir
das tier gehört haben einen riesen
aufgebot von polizei- und was immer
dabei war die frauen die werden
gewaltige angst haben jetzt nicht
einigen jetzt meint man oft egal die
sind ja viele frauen die hier auch
langlaufen viele frauen die ihr alleine
wohnen die keinen mann mehr haben es ist
schon erschreckend was in diesem haus
passiert das kriegt keiner mit denn auch
die nächsten nachbarn die wohnen mehrere
hundert meter weit entfernt und
hilferufe die hätte man überhaupt nicht
hören können die polizei fahndet nach
dem täter bis jetzt erfolglos vermutlich
ist er in ein nahe gelegenes waldstück
geflüchtet dort verlor sich auf seine
spur wir haben mit diensthunden und auch
mit drohnen nach dem tatverdächtigen
besucht wir suchen einen mann der etwa 1
meter 75 groß ist zwischen 16 und 20
jahre alt ist zum tatzeitpunkt trug er
einen pullover einen rotbraunen
schwarzen pullover und dazu eine rote
wollmütze und womöglich hat er leichte
verletzungen an der hand der
gesundheitszustand des opfers ist
inzwischen wieder stabil doch jeden tag
lang irgendwo in deutschland wieder
hunderte einbrecher zu
und was kann man dagegen tun das fragen
wir jetzt kriminaloberrat michael
neumann von chef des hamburger lka 19 zu
der auch die sogenannte soko kassel
gehört getreu dem motto my home is my
castle aber das ist es eben nicht immer
eine trutzburg in der man sicher ist ist
die beobachtung richtig dass die täter
immer brutal arbeiten der normal dass
man nun morgen aus meiner sicht
eindeutig nein es haben sie sich dabei
um absolute einzelfälle
die natürlich dann auch
ihren weg in die presse finden der
normale einbrecher will gerade unerkannt
ins haus und will auch unerkannt wieder
flüchten also aus meinen erfahrungen
absolute einzelfälle die natürlich für
einen geschädigten dann auch dramatisch
sind es ist ja so jeder von uns hat sich
schon mal diese gedanken gemacht man ist
vielleicht allein zu hause man liegt
gerade im bett und man hörte ein
geräusch und das könnte natürlich
wirklich sein dass dort ein einbrecher
gerade eingestiegen ist wie verhalte ich
mich denn dann am besten verstecke ich
mich oder mache ich auf mich aufmerksam
wo ich sofort die polizei was und ihre
tipps
na ja sie haben schon vieles wieder
gegeben
was wir eigentlich als polizei geraten
also auf gar keinen fall
ich sage mal dem täter in den weg
stellen versuchen den täter selbst
festzuhalten oder festzunehmen in
unserem sprachgebrauch aber richtig
machen sich bemerkbar schalten sie licht
ein und rufen sie die polizei aber auch
gar keinen fall dort selbst tätig werden
und den täter dann auch ansprechen oder
beziehungsweise auch festhalten das
führt dann vielleicht zu einem
fluchtverhalten in dessen folge dann
auch jemand geschubst oder beiseite
gedrängt wird und es dann zu einfachen
verletzung kommt also ganz klar nicht
selbst tätig werden rufen sie die
polizei machen sich bemerkbar
und dann wird werden viele dieser
sachverhalte auch ich sag mal schnell zu
ende sein sie arbeiten seit jahren in
der soko castle und sehr erfolgreich
muss man sagen in hamburg gibt es
irgendwelche muster die sie uns
mitteilen könnten also wann schlagen
einbrecher am häufigsten zu wo schlagen
sie haben häufigsten zu was sind
sozusagen die besten voraussetzungen für
einbrecher
ja ich glaube da muss man generell
unterscheiden zwischen dunkler und
heller jahreszeit so sind unsere termini
während in der dunklen jahreszeit
dass es jetzt ich sage mal zwischen den
monaten oktober bis märz da ist der
täter auf der suche nach dunklen häuser
nach dunklen wohnungen da geht es also
darum tatsächlich dann auch eine
anwesenheit vorzutäuschen licht
anzulassen so dass der täter an diesem
haus an dieser wohnung vorbei geht weil
er glaubt dort ist jemand zu hause in
der hellen jahreszeit da geht es
deutlich darum tatgelegenheiten zu
minimieren weil viele täter dort offene
fenster offene türen dann nutzen um in
ein haus einzusteigen also
unterschiedlich je nach jahreszeit kann
man das selbst sehr gut vorsorge treffen
um ein einbruchs risiko zu minimieren
wer sind denn die täter sind das immer
banden sind das einzelgänger was sind
das für menschen
da haben wir ein buntes portfolio also
wir haben reisende täter die extra dazu
aus anderen staaten in die
bundesrepublik deutschland einreisen
aber wir haben natürlich auch örtliche
täter wir haben drogenabhängige die auf
der suche nach tatgelegenheiten nach
einfachen
einfachen objekten dann auch in solche
wohnungen einsteigen also ein buntes
portfolio aber man muss schon sagen dass
gerade reisende täter dass die eine hohe
taktfrequenz dann auch an den tag legen
wenn sie einreisen und das stellt für
uns ein ja schon großes problem dar und
dafür wurde auch die soko kassel ja
gegründet um diese letztlich
wirkungsvoll zu bekämpfen und ich glaube
das ist uns in der vergangenheit sehr
gut gelungen in der tat die bilanz
spricht da sehr für sie vielen dank herr
neumann danke für ihre arbeit
ja dann
schauen wir noch mal auf die maschen wie
gehen die kriminellen üblicherweise vor
wie erkenne ich dass auch ich selbst
opfer werden kann die einbrecher haben
unterschiedliche maschen und zb die
streifen masche ist ganz beliebt ein
solcher klemmen einem plastikstreifen
außen an den türrahmen bleibt er mehrere
tage an derselben stelle gehen die täter
davon aus dass bewohner abwesend sind
auch der social media check ist unter
kriminellen beliebt also wer auf
facebook instagram und co voller
vorfreude den urlaub ankündigt kann ziel
von einbrechern werden bei der
traueranzeigen spionage schlagen täter
bei der kondolenz adresse während der
beerdigung zu und dann gibt es auch noch
die gaunerzinken bezeichnungen und
geheimen symbolen an häusern
kommunizieren die täter dann auch
untereinander
das vorgehen der einbrecher ist gewieft
also und viele eigenheimbesitzer rüsten
auf zum beispiel mit digitalen smarthome
techniken und
überwachungskameras polizeioberrat
harald schmidt vom lka baden württemberg
gilt als der einbruchs experte der
deutschen polizei und klärt uns jetzt
auf was wirklich gegen kriminelle
völlig und morgen aus der zentralen
geschäftsstelle der polizeilichen
kriminalprävention hier im lka in
stuttgart ich habe ihnen das liebste
werkzeug des einbrechers mitgebracht den
schraubendreher und da damit zeige ich
ihnen jetzt gerne mal was an einem
handelsüblichen fenster nur für wenige
handgriffe notwendig sind weil man kann
es ein bisserl salopp auf den punkt
bringen das einzige gesetz und dass sich
einbrecher halten das ist das hebel
gesetz und wie leicht das funktioniert
das demonstriere ich ihnen jetzt hier
mal mit wenigen handgriffen
also ich mach das nicht jeden tag aber
sie sehen
selbst mir gelingt es in wenigen
sekunden ein
handelsübliches fenster wie es in einer
vielzahl von haushalten verbaut ist zu
öffnen und das obwohl ein abschließbarer
fenstergriff montiert war und da können
wir jetzt an der stelle gleich mit einer
mär aufräumen der abschließbarer
fenstergriff alleine der hat nämlich
keinerlei
einbruchhemmende funktion gleichwohl
gehört er aber zu jedem entsprechenden
einbruchsichere fenster wie wir ihnen
das von der polizei empfehlen und ein
entsprechendes modell habe ich ihnen
hier auch mal aufgebaut und sie sehen
auch hier ist ein abschließbarer
fenstergriff dann aber ganz wichtig der
sollte nicht nur abgeschlossen sein
sondern auch der schlüssel gehört
abgezogen denn wenn der täter das glas
angreift und der schlüssel steckt ist es
problemlos zu öffnen wenn wir jetzt hier
ein von uns empfohlene das fenster der
widerstandsklasse rc2 öffnen dann sehen
sie hier das sogenannte
pilzkopf zapfen entsprechend
herausgekommen sind und diese zapfen
sind wirklich um liegend vor jeweils bei
dieser fenstergröße zwei stück und nicht
nur die pilzköpfe sind entscheidend
sondern auch das gegenstück die
entsprechenden schließt stücke das
selber vielleicht mit der kamera hier
unten auch sehr gut weil hier fährt der
pilzkopf wirklich drunter und verhakt
sich und dementsprechend ist es mit dem
schraubendreher nicht möglich hier
entsprechend aufzuhebeln das heißt ganz
wichtig unser ratschlag von der polizei
ist sie brauchen einen soliden
mechanischen grundschutz an fenstern und
türen und diesen sollten sie im
idealfall durch einbruch und überfall
melde technik es viele sichern ihr
zuhause zusätzlich auch noch mit smart
home system was halten sie davon wie
sicher sind die
das smart home system ist lediglich ein
komfort system mit dem sie eine
anwesenheit simulation betreiben können
aber davon gehen keine von der polizei
empfohlen einen
entsprechenden alarmierungs
möglichkeiten aus es ist viel besser
wenn sie entsprechend geprüfte gefahren
wann oder eine alarmanlage einbauen die
hat auch entsprechende smarthome
funktionalitäten aber hier ist
beispielsweise dann sichergestellt dass
sie die rückwirkung freie arbeitet dass
die sogenannte zwangsläufigkeit gegeben
ist das heißt sie können die alarmanlage
scharf schalten wenn auch alle fenster
entsprechen verschlossen sind und türen
und über dieses gerät können sie dann
auch alle anderen smart und geräte im
haus mit steuern aber ganz wichtig ist
dass muss entsprechend über sichere
funktionierende technik der alarm aus
alarmanlage aus geschehen danke für
diese eindrückliche vorführung harald
schmidt mit entertainerqualitäten liegt
vielleicht auch am namen